on commence d'abord par une bonne
nouvelle les marins du porte avions
charles de gaulle sont presque tous hors
de danger sur les 1700 membres de
l'équipage 1046 avait été testé positif
tous sont aujourd'hui guérie sauf un une
issue heureuse à un épisode de
contamination particulièrement important
une fois le virus à bord du navire
militaire la propagation il a été
fulgurante touchant ainsi la grande
majorité des marins y compris 70% de
l'état major
beaucoup de questions s'accumulent est
alors au sujet des circonstances d'une
telle contamination dans un bâtiment si
stratégique des débats alimenté
notamment par les déclarations sous
couvert d'anonymat de certains bars
l'armée a joué avec notre santé notre
vie les mesures barrières étaient
difficiles à respecter à bord du porte
avions nous aurions dû rester à brest
tout ça manque de transparence
auditionné par la commission de la
défense à l'assemblée nationale la
ministre des armées a plus donné
quelques explications
elle est notamment revenu sur l'impact
de la levée des mesures de distanciation
physique au sein de l'équipage
le 30 mars le commandement après la
décision d'assouplir les mesures de
distanciation très strictes qui avaient
été instaurés cette décision a été
provoqué d'une part en raison de la
baisse de moral de l'équipage et ses
conséquences sur la mission et d'autre
part sans doute par un excès de
confiance du commandement ainsi que de
son service médical dans sa maîtrise de
la situation au regard des informations
dont nous disposons aujourd'hui
et j'insiste sur ce terme aujourd'hui il
y a eu des erreurs dans l'appréciation
des mesures à prendre pour combattre le
coronavirus un exercice de transparence
qui intervient après plusieurs épisodes
délicats pour la ministre des armées
ces derniers jours l'association des
journalistes de défense alertait sur des
dérives dans les relations entre
l'institution et leur profession il ya
eu également la sphère du porte avions
la contamination dé de l'équipage du
charles de gaulle qui a qui a défrayé la
chronique dans nos rangs et qui continue
de la défrayer certains disent que la
sitution na a qu'à communiquer des
informations inexactes pouvoir voire
même mensongère
depuis la ministre des armées a promis
une réunion pour clarifier les choses
conséquence ou non florence parle est
présenté ce mardi un nouveau bilan
chiffré
on apprend ainsi que 1771 cas confirmés
ont été détectés au sein des armées
françaises et que cinq mille quatre
cents autres cas probables ont été
également relevés autre dossier sensible
pour le ministère des armées les
témoignages de participants français aux
jeux militaires de one qui se sont
déroulés en octobre dernier
elodie clouvel pentathlètes tricolore
expliqué il ya peu à nos confrères de
télévision loire cet être tombé malade
rentrant de cet événement de quoi
s'interroger sur les circonstances du
retour des sportifs sur le territoire
français depuis consignes auraient été
données aux athlètes participants de ne
plus s'exprimer sur le sujet une
nouvelle illustration du malaise qui
peut exister au sein du ministère des
armées dont la communication est
décidément compliquée la france est
d'ailleurs pas le seul pays à ferrailler
avec ces considérations
on a tous en mémoire la gestion pour le
moins délicate de la situation à bord du
porte avions américain us s theodore
roosevelt où un grand nombre de marins
avait là aussi été infectées